lifestyle influencer megan thomas head
is here with some amazing products
for you and your busy family these
products will keep you looking and
feeling your best
while on the go right megan yes yes i
you know i'm kind of focusing on that
mom on the go because
you know right now with everything going
on mom's schedules have just exploded so
this is
this is for y'all and i want to start
with the fact that sometimes we need
an energy boost something to kind of
give us that boost
this right here is going to do it this
is celsius essential
energy drink it has been clinically
proven to accelerate metabolism
burn fat and calories and like i said
it's going to boost that energy so you
can keep checking out that to-do list
and it's going to do it without crash or
jitters which i really appreciate
there's seven essential vitamins in here
and
none of the junk and you can easily find
it locally in las vegas at smith's
walmart nationally at target and cvs so
some really good stuff
now moving on to kind of a one-stop shop
for some really great mom on the go
ideas this is yuzi
it's an e-commerce store it launched
back in november so it's relatively new
and i love that they encourage
creativity self-expression
inclusivity through style and fashion
and there's so many great things for
moms like scarves
tote bags there's masks there's also
this really cool phone and mask
sanitizer you can just drop it in
sanitize you'd be good to go i love that
machine
and i also want to mention that ten
percent of all their sales
they donate to americans for the arts so
you are looking good you are feeling
good you are doing good i love that so
much
it starts at only about eight dollars
and up for the product so it's really uh
really affordable
uzi.com is where you can find all that
good stuff now
i want to say you know enough you
probably agree with me that moms are
basically the uh multitasking
geniuses of of all of us so i agree i
really love this product
because it helps with that we got to do
all the things all the time
this is from kia babies now kia babies
is a baby and maternity
lifestyle brand they focus on quality
products safety that type of thing
this is their kia babies baby carrier
wrap so it's super soft it's breathable
easy to use it's
versatile and i love that once it's on
you've got the baby strapped in
you don't have to feel like you have to
support the baby you can be hands-free
doing all the things you need to do
while you've got the baby on so it's
really going to take that
baby wearing up to the next level it
retails for only 26.99 and you can
easily find it at amazon
walmart.com and of course kiababies.com
now
the last thing i want to mention is the
fact that you know mom's on the go we
want to be comfortable
but that doesn't mean we can't be
stylish so i'm really excited about this
denim brand this is rev town and they're
kind of like
the most comfortable jeans you've ever
put on your body it's kind of like
wearing sweatpants
they're so wonderful they're a
performance denim brand
and i want to compare them to some
luxury brands because they really are
that fabulous but you get them for a
fraction of the price they're only
79 dollars a pair and they were
developed and designed by guys from
under
armour so you're getting that
performance and comfort of an athletic
pant
but in denim honestly i was taking notes
even for the non-moms on the go right
where can i find more information where
can we find one for me bourbon
bourbonblondeblog.com and my instagram
megan tiffany perfect thank you so much
megan you're so fun